A SECOND SPECIAL COUNSEL TO
INVESTIGATE THE CONNECTION
BETWEEN THE DOJ AND FUSION
G.P.S.
JOINING US NOW HE IS THE
HEAD OF THE AMERICAN CENTER
SEKULOW IS WITH US.
>> HI, SEAN.
>> Sean: I DON'T WANT ONE
FOR THIS.
YEAH ON THE DOSSIER, FUSION
GPS.
HE IS MEETING WITH ELM.
DOING ANTI-TRUMP RESEARCH IN
THE LEAD-UP TO THE CAMPAIGN.
WHAT ABOUT THE FIX BEING IN
PETER STRZOK AND LISA PAGE
BOTH ANTI-TRUMP/PRO-HILLARY
THAT WOULD WE OPEN THE
ENTIRE EMAIL INVESTIGATION
BECAUSE THEY EXONERATED
BEFORE THEY INVESTIGATED.
UNMASKS, JAY.
HOW ABOUT ALL OF THIS NEEDS
TO BE INVESTIGATED.
>> WELL, THE LAST YOU
MENTIONED IS SOMETHING -- I
MEAN, THEY ARE ALL SERIOUS.
THE LAST ONE YOU MENTIONED
THE IDEA OF THAT IT MAY WELL
BE THAT THIS DOES WAY PUT
TOGETHER BY FUSION GPS AND
CHRISTOPHER STEELE AND NOW
BRUCE OHR'S WIFE, BRUCE OHR
WAS FOURTH RANKING OFFICIAL
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
MAY SERVE AS THE BASIS UPON
WHICH A FISA WARRANT WAS
ISSUED.
REMEMBER, THAT FIRST TIME
THEY WENT FOR THAT FISA
WARRANT, IT WAS TURNED DOWN.
THEN THEY GET IT LATER.
WAS IT BASED ON THIS?
IF IT WAS BASED ON THIS, YOU
ARE TALKING ABOUT THE FRUIT
OF THE POISONOUS TREE.
THIS COULD SOMEHOW EXIST
WITHIN OUR SYSTEM OF
JUSTICE, FRANKLY IS
INTERCONNECTIONS AND THIS IS
REALLY SERIOUS TO THE
OPERATION OF JUSTIFIABLE.
THAT'S WHAT'S AT STAKE HERE
HILLARY CLINTON AND THEN
DNC ACCORDING TO DONNA
BRAZILE THAT HER BOUGHT AND
PAID FOR RUSSIAN PROPAGANDA
DOSSIER WITH ALL THE
SALACIOUS DETAILS THAT COULD
HAVE BEEN USED TO ISSUE A
FISA WARRANT AGAINST
CANDIDATE TRUMP,
PRESIDENT-ELECT TRUMP AND
HIS ENTIRE TEAM?
NOW, LEGALLY SPEAKING, IF
THAT HAPPENED, WOULDN'T THAT
RENDER ANY INFORMATION THAT
THEY RECEIVED OUT OF THAT
UNDER FALSE PRETENSES?
ILLEGAL PRETENSES?
>> YES, I MEAN, IF IN FACT,
WHEN THERE IS A LOT OF
CHATTER ABOUT THIS, IF IN
FACT THE FISA WARRANTS BASED
ON THIS UNVERIFIED AS JAMES
COMEY SAID SALACIOUS DOSSIER
WHICH WE KNOW THERE IS NO
VERIFICATION OF ANY OF IT.
IF THAT IN FACT WAS THE
BASIS UPON WHICH THE FISA
WARRANT WAS ISSUED, WELL
THEN, OF COURSE, YOU HAVE A
CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUE WHICH
IS CAN THE EVIDENCE DERIVED
FROM THAT FISA WARRANT,
WHICH RESULTED IN
UNMAVERICKING BE ADMISSIBLE?
AND I THINK THE ANSWER
CLEARLY WOULD BE NO.
>> Sean: OKAY.
NEXT QUESTION.
>> IT DOES RAISE A VERY,
ISSUES.
IT PUTS THIS WHOLE UNMASKING
DOSSIER, WHAT HAVE WE COME
TO?
WHAT IS THE COURT SYSTEM
MY ANALYSIS BASED ON THE
MAY 2ND OR EARLY MAY DRAFT
BY JAMES COMEY AND THEN ALSO
IN THE FBI THAT WAS INVOLVED
IN ALL THESE CASES?
INVESTIGATE IT, EVEN TALK TO
HILLARY OR WITNESSES?
THAT SOUNDS TO ME LIKE
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
BY JAMES COMEY.
>> GRANTED IMMUNITY.
I MEAN, THEY GRANTED
IMMUNITY TO WITNESSES AND
INTERVIEWED THE WITNESSES
THAT WERE GRANTED IMMUNITY.
SO GO FIGURE THAT OUT.
WHAT PROSECUTOR DOES THAT?
AND THEN IF YOU LOOK AT THE
ACTUAL -- AND WE BROKE THIS
OUT, SEAN.
IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT WAS
DRAFTED BY JAMES COMEY AND
HIS DRAFT AND WAS EDITED BY
PETER STRZOK AND OTHERS, YOU
LOOK AT THINGS LIKE BIG
DISCUSSION, THE WHOLE BASIS
ON WHICH THIS WHOLE EMAIL
SITUATION CAME TO LIGHT WAS
THE FACT THAT THE SERVER WAS
NOT SECURED.
COMEY'S ORIGINAL DRAFT, WHEN
TALKING ABOUT THE
CONCERNING BECAUSE ALL OF
THESE EMAILS WERE HOUSED ON
LIKE THOSE FOUND AT THE
DEPARTMENT AND AGENCIES OF
THE UNITED STATES
GOVERNMENT.
THAT WAS OMITTED FROM THE
FINAL REPORT.
HE WROTE IT AND THEN SOMEONE
TOOK THAT OUT.
THAT WAS THE BASIS UPON
WHICH THIS WHOLE MATTER
STARTED IN THE FIRST PLACE.
>> Sean: LET ME GO BACK TO
TOP STORY TONIGHT.
WE NOW HAVE JOHN SOLOMON'S
EXPLOSIVE REPORT.
AND OCCUPY AND UP STARTING
IN OCTOBER.
WE ARE AT FIRST 10,000,
50,000, 100,000, 200,000.
THEN WE GET TO TWO DAYS
BEFORE THE ELECTION.
MONEY CAME FROM.
STORY ABOUT DONALD TRUMP.
IF THAT STORY CAN COME OUT,
I DOUBT WE WOULD HAVE KNOWN
IT WAS PAID FOR BECAUSE WE
DIDN'T KNOW THAT ANYBODY WAS
BEING PAID UP UNTIL TODAY.
TERMS OF
>> Sean: PARTICIPATE AT ALL
IN IT.
>> Sean: SALACIOUS LIES.
RUSSIAN CONNECTION.
COLLUSION IF YOU WILL.
NOW HAVE YOU TWO DAYS BEFORE
THE ELECTION.
A MASSIVE SUM OF MONEY FOR
>> WELL, BECAUSE WHAT HAVE
YOU IS, SEAN, AND THIS IS --
LOOK AT THE WHOLE PROCESS.
YOU TALK ABOUT THE NEED FOR
A SPECIAL COUNSEL.
LOOK AT ALL OF THIS THAT'S
GOING ON.
AND THEN YOU GO BACK TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE ITSELF
AND THE FBI AND, LIKE YOU, I
HAVE TREMENDOUS RESPECT FOR
THE AGENTS THAT PUT THEIR
LIVES ON THE LINE FOR US
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
DEFENDING THIS COUNTRY.
DEFENDING OUR FREEDOM.
I WILL TELL YOU WHAT I DON'T
APPRECIATE.
I DON'T APPRECIATE A
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE THAT
NOT ONLY HAD DETERMINED THE
CASE BEFORE THE EVIDENCE
CAME IN BUT WAS COMPLETELY
AND IT'S BECOME VERY CLEAR
HERE, CONFLICTED ON MULTIPLE
LEVELS.
AND THAT IS NOT -- I DIDN'T
THINK REPUBLICAN, DEMOCRAT,
INDEPENDENT, NO ONE IN OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL REPUBLIC
SHOULD TAKE THAT AS OKAY.
IT'S NOT OKAY.
THE HEAD OF THE FBI IN -- BY
THE WAY, WE TALK ABOUT THE
DEEP STATE.
THIS IS RIGHT AT THE.